I think we should make a distinction
between Islam and Muslims.
What I'm trying to do is to say all over
the world,
we can identify with each other as human
beings.
That is the basic,
um,
glue.
The fact that you are an individual
human being and I'm an individual human
being.
That's what's,
that's where our common commonality or
common strength lies in and common
interest Islam.
If we view it as one of the philosophies
are political theories or ideas produced
by human beings throughout history,
just one of them and view,
it's,
scrutinize it,
criticize it as we have done with all
other doctrines,
religious or secular,
um,
then we may be able from the West.
Now I'm using [inaudible] as in someone
who is Westernized,
convinced Muslims to make a different
choice and to reform their faith fast by
acknowledging that there are things
wrong with their faith.
So our goal should not be to be,
to preserve Islam.
Our goal should be the common human,
you know,
we are,
we are human.
So Muslims are humans.
They're not fast meal point just as a
baby in Pakistan or in Saudi Arabia or
in Yemen or in a Muslim community here.
If we emphasize that,
then I think we can make that change.
And that involves two things.
That involves learning to distinguish
between who is an enemy and who is a
friend.
But before you decide who is an enemy
and who is a friend,
you yourself have to decide what do you
stand for?
What are your own set of ideas that you
feel as superior to that of Islam?
And Are you willing to defend and die
for your own ideas of freedom and
humanity and humanism as much as the
fanatics are willing to die for their
own.
There is no consensus in the United
States on who the enemies and whether to
really say it's Islam or it's a
perversion of a form of Islams.
It will have is himself as in what was
it basically just slam a who should we
ally with strategically?
Um,
in other words,
the approach has been very much
strategic.
There are people in the United States
including this administration who are
waking up to the fact that it is,
there is a battle of ideas going on,
but they're too shy to voice what the
ideas are.
Um,
another point of criticism,
and that's not only towards this
administration,
but I've seen how it all over the place
is just this,
this desire to avoid Saudi Arabia as a
culprit of,
you know,
the states that's not only financing
terrorism but also financing the
ideology behind the terror act.
I think it was a mistake to declare a
war on terror.
Tara is just a tactic and it shows how
much,
how strategic the whole approach is to
watch what's going on.
Um,
another mistake both on both sides of
the Atlantic is lit.
If we just appeased them.
If you just understand what they want
from us and we give it to them,
they might not be so,
so bad to us.
So they might forget what the mates,
I think those are mistakes that were
made.
But again,
I'll come back to the distinction
between Europe and America.
And it seems as if America is learning
much faster than Europe and my learning,
I mean waking up to the fact that it is
Islam,
not necessarily all Muslims,
but Islamism set of ideas and that
that's kind of mean military.
I mean very disastrous military action,
which is for every politician is a
terrible decision to take to say,
we are going tall,
we are going to do something destructive
or we're going to take an unpopular
action.
And American seem to be much more
courageous in making that decision.
They did in the student the Second World
War and later then the Europeans who
have I,
I think that European data ship at the
point,
this point is fairly self district,
and I say this because of the,
the approach to Iran.
Okay.